AND THE HILLS MEDIA REPORTER
JOE CONCHA.
I REMEMBER A MOMENT WHERE YOU
SAID THAT CNN WOULDN'T PUT YOU
ON BECAUSE THEY DISAGREE WITH
YOU.
FOR THE RECORD, YOU'VE ATTACKED
ME ON MY OWN SHOW AND I STILL
INVITE YOU BACK ON.
>> FOX HAS ALWAYS HAD A MUCH
MORE DIVERSE APPROACH, I HAVE
ARGUED WITH TUCKER CARLSON AND
LAURA INGRAHAM, NOBODY HAS EVER
TOLD ME WHAT TO SAY ON THIS SHOW
OR ANY OTHER SHOW.
>> Sean: GOOD LUCK IF THEY
TRY.
>> I STAND UP FOR CIVIL
LIBERTIES NO MATTER WHO THE
PRESIDENT IS.
IF HILLARY CLINTON HAD BEEN
ELECTED PRESIDENT AND THEY WERE
TRYING TO IMPEACH OR I WOULD'VE
WRITTEN A BOOK CALLED THE CASE
AGAINST THE PREACHING
HILLARY CLINTON.
CONGRESS CAN'T IMPEACH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE
CONSTITUTION PROVIDES CRITERIA
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
TREASON, BRIBERY, HIGH CRIMES
AND MISDEMEANORS, UNLESS THERE
IS COMPELLING EVIDENCE,
IMPEACHMENT ISN'T
CONSTITUTIONALLY PERMISSIBLE.
>> Sean: THIS IS NOT YOUR
FORMAL SUMMER LIBERTARIAN
FRIENDS, YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE
SEAN HANNITY WHO YOU ARE MORE
ALIGNED WITH
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,L
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,O
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,K
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,A
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,T
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,C
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,M
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,Y
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,B
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,A
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,G
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,N
LIKE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND SPINE,,
THEY LITERALLY SET UP SOMETHING
THEY WOULDN'T DO ANOTHER
ADMINISTRATIONS.
A33 YEAR WAR VETERAN?
I'M SORRY, THAT'S NOT THE
AMERICA I LOVE, THAT'S NOT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC THAT
PROTECTS CIVIL LIBERTIES.
>> I AGREE, I WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERY AMERICAN, CONSERVATIVE,
LIBERAL, CENTRIST, RIGHT, OR
LEFT SUPPORTS THE CONSTITUTION
AND SUPPORTS CIVIL LIBERTIES NO
MATTER WHO THE TARGET IS,
BECAUSE TODAY IT'S A REPUBLICAN,
TOMORROW IT CAN BE A DEMOCRAT,
TOMORROW IT CAN BE YOU.
PRESERVE YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT FOR CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
DON'T LET POLITICS INTERFERE.
>> Sean: YOU STILL HAVE A
TOUGH TIME WITH THOSE 33,000
EMAILS DELETED.
>> I'M TO HAVE AN INVESTIGATION,
COMEY WAS WRONG WHEN HE WENT
BEYOND IT.
>> Sean: FROM THE MEDIA
STANDPOINT, THEY ARE BEGGING,
DEMOCRATS, DO THIS.
THEY WANTED SO BAD, THEY DON'T
CARE WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> NOR ARE THEY ALIGNED WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, QUINNIPIAC HAD
A POLL TODAY.
IF ONE-THIRD OF AMERICANS
SUPPORT IMPEACHMENT INCLUDING
JUST 35% OF INDEPENDENTS, THAT
IS THE WHOLE BALL GAME.
REMEMBER THE BRETT KAVANAUGH
HEARINGS AND WHAT IT DID FOR A
RATINGS PERSPECTIVE ACROSS THE
BOARD, IT WOULD BE LIKE A
STEROID SHOT FOR THESE NETWORKS
THAT ARE STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW
POST MUELLER REPORT BECAUSE
THERE'S FATIGUE AROUND THESE
SORTS OF THINGS.
IN TERMS OF RACHEL MADDOW WHO
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER, IT'S WHY
PEOPLE LIKE ME, OBJECTIVE PEOPLE
LOOK AT HER MODERATING A DEBATE
AND SAY THAT CAN'T HAPPEN
BECAUSE IN 2016 SHE MODERATED A
DEBATE AND WENT UP ON STAGE IN
NATIONAL TELEVISION AND HUG TO
BERNIE SANDERS AND
HILLARY CLINTON ON STAGE.
PICTURE SHANNON BREAM OR
MARTHA MacCALLUM DOING THAT TO
A REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE.
THE APOCALYPSE WOULD LOOK LIKE
NOTHING COMPARED TO THE
REACTION.
>> Sean: I THINK I COULD HOST
A DEBATE, WE WOULD DO A GREAT
JOB.
I'M LOOKING AT PROFESSOR
ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
>> WE NEED TO GET BACK TO WALTER
CRONKITE-TYPE JOURNALISM WHERE
PEOPLE CAN TRUST WHAT THEY HEAR
IN THE MEDIA.